hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the midnight
man ok this is a game that's apparently
based off of a real ritual to summon a
real demon so if you guys want to do
this for yourself and summon a monster
into your own home try this method right
now wait what's the method ok this is
the method the paper/pencil needle
Candlebox a matches a door and a salt or
salt turn off all the lights like a
candle write your name on the paper
first middle last prick your little
finger with needle and add a drop of
blood on the paper allowed to soak in
place paper with your name on floor in
front of door knock on door 22 times
with the ticking of the clock the twenty
second dogmas Sakura 12 a.m. open your
door get on the floor everybody do the
dinosaur oh sorry you have now summon
the midnight man oh if you do the
dinosaur you'll summon the dinosaur man
you don't want to summon the dinosaur
man dinosaur man not as fun as a
midnight man ok anyway so I don't know
what we're gonna do this game but I
guess we're gonna summon the midnight
man so if you guys weren't paying
attention we're gonna do this farce
hell's also linked in the description
below I'll play for you
obviously the midnight man is that
someone knocking on the door I'm
guessing this is after we've summoned
the midnight man oh no oh no I shouldn't
be so sarcastic and now yeah he's at the
trailing end of the ritual
so we lit my candle again ooh nice fire
effect it's mad on the unity engine and
we got a little clock in the corner I
can't see very far as per as is expected
with a freaking candle ok so he summoned
the midnight man where is he is he in
the bathroom taking a dump no ok fine
then I guess he's not nice house how did
I suffer why would anyone want to summon
the midnight man why would anyone think
oh I'm a TV what wait a minute
Tom now right here that TV NOS going to
be on
I'll go down there later uh check on you
later okay computer den office area
Sears this house really nice
okay let's just turn on all the TVs cuz
why not why not master bathroom
oh yes nice that toilet that looks
comfortable oh yeah so enough mocking of
the setting let's get down to big hello
is someone there to murder my giblets
why doesn't this door open is that the
midnight man's room ooh
pool what what'd you do I heard a noise
don't think you can mess with me hi hon
ha ha ha god damn it screw you gonna be
like that is it gonna be like that huh
phew that's how it's gonna be a ton of a
[ __ ] oh you're ready then that's gonna
be one of these games eh see which lets
just open everything and leave
everything open cuz that's that's how to
distract that know relight really like
we like relight light like what's that
over there what's that over there what
was that
who's that what was going on like that
all the chairs okay the chairs are
freaking out okay that's okay there we
go okay we got our light again ha ha ha
seriously why would anyone voluntarily
summon the midnight man does not seem
like good idea
hello okay that's on can I rush this
let's uh run away screaming outside no
okay I'll go back inside okay I'm inside
outside inside I'm inside I swear I'm
inside you gonna wha okay you're not
supposed to leave the freaking house
apparently all right then
well play your game you rogue so don't
leave the house is basically the gist of
it oh ha ha ha oh no let's give this
another try without dying horribly I'm
just assuming that you know there would
be some reward for summoning the
midnight man maybe if you survive him
you get like a trophy or a little
sticker or some something to signify
that this wasn't a horrible idea
no nothing okay all right whatever
all right let's sprint through the house
thank you for opening that door for me I
was already on my way to there anything
here usually here maybe I just got
survived till morning that's what I got
to do that's what's got to happen
hey nice food can I go take a swim ha ha
ha
can I take a nap wait oh I can't jump
down okay just zooming through my house
don't mind me turn that off
who's turning on all my appliances I
don't much care for this what is that
how long has that been there oh hello ok
turn that on get some light what's over
here I haven't been in this room before
Sam deal man how many bathrooms does
this friggin place have seriously this
is like a bajillion dollar home what cat
TV who the TV right there
this is stupid I'm jealous of this guy's
crappy house I hear you you gonna jump
at me you're gonna jump at me aren't you
I'm reading for here who's that Oh what
duh what the hell was that
looks like some things are changing okay
that okay the chairs are now ah god damn
it I would I knew it was gonna happen
still loud noise anyway hello
okay so I can't go outside that's for
damn sure
I will die if I go outside so what I
need to do I say oh I see you there
hi hey buddy how you doing what's going
you're doing a little dance there you
doing a little dance whoa whoa whoa whoa
how you like the lighting man you look
good
you've been working out man you're
glistening you're gone
say you wanna come inside to one of my
nine beds uh uh yeah no okay I find that
scro yo go away clean my damn pool and
get out of here you going now
no he's still there oh that's oh so
spooky all right go back upstairs see it
sound around it's that creepy guy just
guy staying there I'm gonna call the
police
a car the police don't think I won't as
I will don't don't try me I love a man
on the edge
I'm done waiting for something to happen
so far nothing's happening besides I
mean the midnight man standing ominously
in plain view but ending here before oh
hi you're in here hey how's it going
Oh
dummy house dummy ah shouldn't have gone
near him okay I'm done with this you can
try for yourself I mean it's not bad but
at least someone's taking an original
aspect to a horror game it's not the
best I've ever played but at least I
something there there's a strong effort
to try to create something original
which is kind of like what paranormal
did you around the house and interesting
things happen I mean paranormal did it
better that's not to say this isn't a
good effort I mean I applaud anyone that
goes out and tries to make a game for
themselves so no not work out better
than others it got me a few times but
mostly just through the jump scares that
was that so anyway try for yourself let
me know what you think thank you all so
much for watching clicking the dates of
four videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video bye
you all
the calm
Oh
love
returned three